hi it's dayton bernat and like drew i
love trying food from all different
cities all over the united states
whenever i travel and our friends at
either want to show us three amazing
spots for next time you are out about
for you try let's check them out
[Music]
hey drew my name is bert jackson glidden
i'm the editor of eater portland and i'm
at one of my all-time favorite
restaurants in portland han oak
hanok opened six years ago we had to
close
for the past couple years but we
reopened with an exciting new menu
of hot pot it's communal i love that it
serves as canvas for our mix of korean
japanese shop
chinese hot pot it's really just getting
to share a meal around this communal pot
we start off with a big plate of shaved
meats local vegetables
and then once people are done with that
we kind of transition into a dumping and
noodle course
it's really fun and interactive and
delicious
hi drew i'm tierney eater baltimore's
editor i'm here at one of my favorite
spots in the city cindy lou's fifth
house with chef and owner cindy wolf
herself hi drew i worked in charleston
south carolina at the beginning of my
career and i love lowcountry cooking i
kind of went back to our roots with this
concept having all the wonderful crab
and raw fish and oysters and beautiful
things that our waterways produce
serving it and making you feel
comfortable and happy and enjoying a
great view well the food is incredible
the atmosphere is lovely thank you for
having us hi drew thank you
hey drew it's ollie the editor of peter
miami and today i'm at one of my
favorite restaurants in town hoya day
with the co-owner alex who's going to
tell us a little bit about this
beautiful restaurant
what sets us apart is that with our
extensive background the fine dining
cuisine that bring these ingredients and
these techniques that you don't really
find in these neighborhood restaurants
and put it in this package of something
really cute and affordable and
approachable where you're not
intimidated by
some big blitzy thing and you can just
get these nice things like caviar foie
gras slightly different meats like
rabbit fresh pasta and feel at home
while getting to enjoy these things
until
those restaurants look amazing i hope to
see you there
[Music]